WE'RE GOING TO GET TO EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW.
LAST NIGHT, THERE WAS A LOT OF
PEACEFUL PROTESTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
MORE PEACEFUL THAN OTHER NIGHTS.
SO THAT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
ALSO TODAY, ALL FOUR POLICE
OFFICERS WERE CHARGED IN THE
MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD
SO HERE'S HOPING FOR SOME
JUSTICE FOR THAT FAMILY.
AND THERE'S MANY MORE FAMILIES
THAT DESERVE JUSTICE, AS WELL.
BUT AGAIN, THESE ARE ALL STEPS
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT GUESTS TONIGHT ARE SENATOR
KAMALA HARRIS.
WE ALSO HAVE TALIB KWELI, WHO IS
A RAPPER AND ACTIVIST, AND WE
GET TO CATCH UP.
WE'VE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR A
LONG TIME.
AND WE ALSO GET TO HEAR FROM
COMEDIAN ROY WOOD, JR.
IT'S GOING TO BE A FUN SHOW.
LET'S GET SOME NEWS HERE, YOU
GUYS
AFTER NINE DAYS OF PROTESTS, A
NEW POLL FOUND THAT PRETTY MUCH
EVERYONE THINKS PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOT DOING A GOOD JOB.
CHECK IT OUT
>> RIGHT NOW, BASED ON THE DATA
WE HAVE, THE PUBLIC IS NOT WITH
THIS PRESIDENT
HIS APPROVAL RATING CONTINUES TO
BE TERRIBLE, 54% DISAPPROVAL
>> YEAH, NOT GOOD.
EVEN WORSE FOR TRUMP, THAT POLL
WAS TAKEN AMONG HIS KIDS
RIGHT NOW, TRUMP SEEMS TO BE
POLLING SOMEWHERE BETWEEN JAKE
PAUL AND THAT TIME I DECIDED TO
GROW A MUSTACHE FOR THE SUMMER
YOU LIKED IT
>> I DID
I WAS THE ONE.
>> Jimmy: MY HEAVENS
THERE'S GOT TO BE SOMEONE ELSE
NO, PROBABLY NOT
WHEN TRUMP SAW HIS NUMBERS, HE
STARTED CRYING AND THEN HE WAS
LIKE, I'M NOT CRYING, IT'S THE
TEAR GAS FOR MY CHURCH PHOTO
SHOOT BLOWING BACK IN MY FACE.
EVERYONE SEEMS TO BE TURNING ON
HIM.
FOX AND FRIENDS IS NOW JUST FOX
AND FRIEND
YOU KNOW, AT THIS POINT, TRUMP
SHOULD JUST GO FOR 100%
DISAPPROVAL AND TAKE CREDIT FOR
UNITING THE COUNTRY.
TRUMP'S THINKING CAN TURN THIS
AROUND
TOMORROW HE'S GOING TO WALK TO
THE VATICAN, HOLD UP A BIBLE AND
BE LIKE, OKAY, POPE FRANCIS.
HOW DOES TRUMP NOT KNOW HOW TO
HOLD A BOOK?
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYONE HOLD --
THIS IS -- HAVE YOU EVER SEEN
ANYONE HOLD ANYTHING LIKE THAT
IT'S LIKE A BROKEN G.I. JOE HAND
OR SOMETHING
I'VE NEVER -- IT'S LIKE HE'S
PLUCKING THE BIBLE FROM THE
BIBLE TREE
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYBODY -- HAVE
YOU EVER -- HONEY, HAVE YOU READ
THIS
ANYONE WANT TO READ THIS
PUT YOUR HAND DOWN NOW ON THE
CUP.
MEANWHILE, FORMER PRESIDENT
GEORGE BUSH RELEASED A STATEMENT
THAT SOME PEOPLE THINK IS A SHOT
AT TRUMP
HE WROTE, THOSE WHO SET OUT TO
SILENCE THOSE VOICES DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE MEANING OF
AMERICA OR HOW IT BECOMES A
BETTER PLACE
YOU KNOW IT'S SERIOUS IF THEY
GOT GEORGE W. BUSH TO WRITE
WORDS.
EVEN PAT ROBERTSON CALLED OUT
DONALD TRUMP FOR HIS RESPONSE TO
THE PROTEST.
THIS IS AMAZING.
WATCH THIS
>> HE SAID, I'M READY TO SEND IN
MILITARY TROOPS IF THE NATION'S
GOVERNORS DON'T ACT TO QUELL THE
VIOLENCE
HE SPOKE OF THEM AS BEING JERKS.
YOU JUST DON'T DO THAT, MR.
PRESIDENT.
IT ISN'T COOL.
>> YEAH, HE WAS LIKE, THIS ISN'T
COOL
P-ROD'S OUT.
MICROPHONE DROP.
YOU KNOW WE LIVE IN CRAZY TIMES
WHEN WE'RE AGREEING WITH THE GUY
THAT SAID GAY PEOPLE CAUSE
HURRICANES
THERE'S MORE OF THE COUNTRY
TURNING ON TRUMP, REPUBLICAN
SENATORS HAVE VERY LITTLE TO
SAY.
>> WHAT THE DID DID LAST NIGHT,
WAS IT THE RIGHT THING
IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID RIGHT?
SENATOR, ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED A @ WHITE HOUSE
LAST NIGHT
>> HE WAS ASKED THE SAME
QUESTION AFTER COMING BACK FROM
LUNCH.
LAST WEEK, TRUMP WAS RUSHED TO
THE WHITE HOUSE BUNKER BECAUSE
OF THE PROTEST
EARLIER TODAY, TRUMP SAID THE
REPORT WAS FALSE
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WELL, IT WAS A FALSE REPORT
I WASN'T THERE
I WENT DOWN DURING THE DAY, AND
I WAS THERE FOR A TINY LITTLE
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
IT WAS MUCH MORE FOR AN
INSPECTION
>> YEAH, IT'S LIKE RUNNING INTO
A FRIEND AT THE CVS BUYING
HEMORRHOID SCREAM.
I'M NOT BUYING, WHAT IS THIS
HEMORRHOID CREAM
I'M JUST INSPECTING.
I'M A HEMORRHOID CREAM
INSPECTOR.
WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL?
AND FINALLY, AFTER A ROUGH FEW
DAYS, HERE'S SOMETHING TO BRING
US UP.
>> SO WE'RE GOING TO START
MANUFACTURING DOSES OF THE
VACCINES
>> AND HERE'S SOMETHING TO BRING
US BACK DOWN
>> BUT IF IT ACTS LIKE OTHER
COMMON VIRUS -- COMMON
CORONAVIRUSES, IT'S LIKELY NOT
GOING TO BE A VERY LONG DURATION
OF IMMUNITY.